hasta el momento hemos supuesto que la
tasa de descuento es la misma sin
importar la longitud del periodo de
tiempo del cual estamos hablando pero si
vas a un banco y dices y banco quiero
invertir mi dinero en un cedé de un niño
te va a contestar algo así como ok un
certificado depósito o sea cd de un año
te da un 2% que tal que te doy mi dinero
por dos años puedes guardar con llave mi
dinero por más tiempo y entonces te
vamos a dar una tasa de intereses más
grande porque tenemos más flexibilidad
con dos años y no tenemos que
preocuparnos en pagarte tan rápido y
entonces te podemos dar un 7% de hecho
sabes que no necesito mi dinero por diez
años
si nos das tu dinero por diez años te
vamos a dar una tasa de interés del 12%
en general y tiende a ser el caso aunque
no siempre lo es entre más tiempo
renuncias al acceso a tu dinero mayor es
la tasa de interés que obtienes y por lo
tanto lo mismo sucede con la tasa de
descuento por lo general la tasa de
descuento de un pago dentro de dos años
es mayor que la de un pago dentro de un
año y cómo se hace eso
ya estemos sin riesgo entonces si fueras
a comprar un bono del gobierno la tasa
sobre un niño
hasta sobre un niño digamos que solo te
van a dar el 1%
y digamos que si les prestas tu dinero
dos años
te van a dar 5 % por año que es lo que
eso significa veamos el ejemplo eso
significa que podemos tomar los 100
pesos y prestar los al gobierno durante
un año y te van a dar el 1 por ciento de
interés o sea tenemos que multiplicar
por 1.20 1 y nos quedan 101 pesos muy
bien
ahora la otra opción es prestar lo
durante dos años y entonces no vas a ver
tu dinero no vas a verle ni el pelo
durante dos años pero vas a obtener una
tasa del 5% por año
entonces calculemos cuánto obtendrías
después de dos años
y eso va a ser igual a una calculadora
si por el interés de un niño 1.05 por el
interés del segundo año ya que pues lo
podemos ver así como 1.05 al cuadrado y
obtenemos 110 pesos con 25 centavos
entonces son 110 pesos con 25 centavos
entonces bueno no estamos haciendo valor
actual esto lo podemos ver más o menos
como un valor del futuro
si tomas el valor futuro de la primera
opción puedes ver que es mejor que el de
la segunda opción cuando tienes este
tipo de tasas de interés que dependen de
la cantidad del tiempo que prestas tu
dinero pero bueno hablemos de valor
actual cuál es el valor actual de estos
110 pesos pues o sea el valor actual 1
empezamos con los 100 pesos el valor
actual de estos 100 pesos son 100 pesos
otra vez pero cuál es el valor actual
los 110 pesos son 110 y vamos a usar la
tasa de descuento de los dos años porque
osea no puedes tocar tu dinero por dos
años entonces sería equivalente a
prestar tu dinero durante dos años
entonces tenemos que dividir entre 1.05
al cuadrado al cuadrado porque son dos
años seguimos la calculadora
creo que el primer problema pero bueno a
ver 110 entre 1.0 5 al cuadrado
son 99 puntos 77 pesos o sea si era el
primer problema mírenlo ahí está en
verde y este es muy interesante no los
20 pesos de los pagan hoy y esto es muy
importante cuando te estén hablando del
año 1 o del año 2 es muy importante
saber si eso es hoy si esos dentro de un
año porque si es dentro de un año
tendrías que aplicar un descuento con la
tasa de un año y si eso no le aplica el
descuento pero bueno el pago de los 20
pesos es hoy entonces su valor actual
son 20 pesos más 50 pesos ahora de los
50 pesos que usamos la tasa de un niño a
la tasa de 2 años pues la tasa de un año
no porque no estamos renunciando al
acceso a los 50 pesos por dos años sólo
por uno entonces más 50 pesos dividido
entre la tasa de un niño hace a 1.01 más
35 pesos
dividido entre la tasa de dos años pero
o sea son tasas por año entonces y son
dos años entonces tenemos que descontar
los dos veces sea dividir entre 1.05 al
cuadrado sacando la calculadora y
tenemos 20 más
50 entre 1.0 uno más
35 / 1.05 al cuadrado
y eso es igual a
101 pesos con 25 centavos 101 pesos con
25 centavos entonces mira no cambie
ninguno de los flujos de pago en ninguno
de los tres escenarios y bueno déjame
pongo una línea separando cada uno de
los escenarios y ese es el escenario 2
este es el escenario 3 pero en el
escenario 1 como usamos una tasa de
descuento del 5%
para todas las digamos duraciones
obtuvimos que la opción número 1 era la
mejor opción
pero si queremos la tasa de descuento al
2% y por cualquier razón podemos
prestarle nuestro dinero al gobierno
sobre cualquier intervalo de tiempo al
2% interés entonces la opción 2 se
vuelve la mejor opción
y finalmente si tenemos este tipo de
tasas que de hecho es el escenario más
realista de todos y aunque las cuentas
son muy sencillas estamos haciendo algo
bastante sofisticado cuando tenemos las
dos tasas distintas para préstamos de un
año y de dos años y tienen que ser justo
estos números tuvo que jugar con ellos
para que saliera el resultado entonces
la opción 3 se vuelve la mejor opción y
quiero dejarte esto a ti el porque fue
mejor para la opción 3 que para la
opción 2 y si realmente lo entiendes
creo que entonces ya tienes muy buena
intuición sobre el valor actual y bueno
lo que estamos aprendiendo aquí es el
flujo de efectivo descontado y qué
exceso del flujo de efectivo descontado
te estoy dando un flujo de efectivo 20
pesos hoy 50 pesos dentro de un año 35
pesos dentro de dos años y tú los estás
descontando para obtener el valor actual
y bueno cuando alguien dice hoy yo puedo
usar excel para hacer un flujo de
efectivo descontado esto es justo lo que
están haciendo
estén haciendo alguna su posición sobre
las tasas de descuento y están usando
estas cuentas bastante sencillas para
obtener el valor actual de este flujo de
efectivo es una técnica muy poderosa
porque vas a excel y dices ah tengo un
negocio y basándome en mis suposiciones
digo en el año 1 ahorita me va a dar 20
pesos después de un año me va a dar 50
pesos y después de 235 ahora que sea
fuera de riesgo es suponer muchísimo
pero si lo fuera podrías utilizar estas
tasas de descuento y pues estimar y
decir que el negocio vale 101 pesos con
25 centavos y eso es lo que estoy
dispuesto a pagar por él si puede
obtenerlo por 90 pesos eso es un muy
buen trato para mí eso es todo lo que el
flujo de efectivo descontado es pero la
gran moraleja de esto es lo dependiente
que es el valor actual de lo que
suponemos de las tasas de descuento las
tasas de descuento lo son todo en
finanzas y es justo aquí donde las
finanzas se alejan de otros campos
especialmente de las ciencias realmente
no
una respuesta correcta todo se basa en
suposiciones todos estos flujos de
efectivo descontados y modelos son para
que entiendas la dinámica que hay detrás
algo que pasa mucho en el mundo real de
las finanzas si alguna vez te vuelves un
analista en un banco de inversión
probablemente el acceso pero puedes
obtener casi cualquier valor actual
escogiendo la tasa de descuento adecuada
y el chiste es escoger la tasa de
descuento más cercana a la realidad
tomando en cuenta que todo es sin riesgo
todos tus pagos están garantizados pero
sabemos que el mundo real no es así si
estás invirtiendo en la tienda de
mascotas y te dicen que te van a pagar
estos flujos de efectivo eso no está
libre de riesgo de hecho la mayor parte
de finanzas se trata de encontrar esa
tasa de descuento
ese es el hilo negro porque eso cambia
cuál de las opciones es la mejor bueno
no quiero confundirte demasiado lo que
tienes aquí es una herramienta muy
poderosa con la cual si puedes pensar
una tasa de descuento entonces puedes
comparar entre 3 o 10 o las que sean
distintas formas de pago y eso es muy
útil no tiene ni idea la cantidad de
cosas en el mundo que son de esta forma
hay estas esquemas de pago para la
colegiatura de universidad de los hijos
donde alguna compañía le pagas 250 pesos
a lo largo de 20 años y después en el
año 21 ellos están dispuestos a pagar la
colegiatura de la universidad y puedes
calcular cuánto dinero están ganando
ellos con esto haciendo el flujo de
efectivo descontado y claro cuando tú
estás pagando estos números se vuelven
negativos
te veo en el próximo vídeo